Tu sais, moi, dès que je suis
en flirt avec une meuf—
ouais, j'emploie des mots
des années 80.
♪ Pour un flirt avec toi ♪
Non, là, ça se voit.
>> Faut que tu fasses, hé, regarde !
Excuse-moi.
>> Maintenant, il faut que tu fasses comme ça.
Attends, hé, deux secondes,
attends, deux secondes.
C'est super vite.
>> Juste du bout des doigts, juste du bout des doigts.
'Tain, je sens le vent, mon gars !
Le truc, il va à 8 000 à l'heure.
Par contre, il faut
que t'ais l'air un peu—
Mmh-mmh.
Tout à l'heure, elle m'a griffé de ouf, quoi !
Ah je saigne ! Nooon !
Je l'ai griffé avec mon petit doigt.
Ah ouais, tu m'as fouetté
la gueule, quoi !
Putain, je me fais défoncer,
c'est abusé.
Un, deux, trois,
attends, attends, attends.
Ah putain !
>> Ah, elle était parfaite, là.
Attends, on joue là.
Tu fais quoi, là ? [rires]
Attendez qu'il suce
sa banane, wesh !
Il l'a léchée toute à l'heure,
c'est vrai en plus.
Ah ! Ah ! Arrête ! Madmoizelle !
>> Ha ha !
>> Madmoizelle.com !
Grosse vanne, quoi !
>> Toi, t'allumes quand j'ai tout raconté la vanne, quoi.
Vanne terminée ?
On enregistre.
Normalement, c'est le même point, donc—
tu peux me passer le lubrifiant s'il te plaît ?
Et me le mettre
un peu sur la bite ?
Alors, ce truc, je crois,
dégouline un peu.
C'est vraiment dégueulasse.
C'est du vrai lubrifiant.
Par contre, t'es vraiment la meuf
pas du tout joueuse avec moi.
T'es vraiment la—
>> Ah, faut qu'on soit —
1 %, quoi.
>> OK.
Au moins, niveau smile.
>> C'est vraiment la meuf comme ça—
Non, mais c'est clair, c'est vraiment—
>> Qu'est-ce que je fous là en fait ?
J'en ai 16,
ainsi qu'un max de lubrifiant.
Extrêmement mal joué.
J'ai trop envie de t'embrasser.
Ah putain,
mon froc est détruit.
C'est dégueulasse au soja, putain !
Oui, surtout, ce qui dégueulasse,
c'est mon froc, quoi !
Il a mis un immeuble.
Elle croit
que t'es portugais.
Peut-être qu'elle veut
que tu lui achètes un immeuble.
Ou peut-être
qu'elle connaît quelqu'un...
Non ! Ah, t'es nul !
Ha ha ha !
Attends, je suis
un autre homosexuel, là.
Aaah ! C'est du porno !
Elle veut pas le faire,
je te jure, je veux pas le faire.
Vas-y !
Aaah!
Mais depuis qu'elle a dit
que je puais de la gueule,
j'ai l'impression que je pues
de la gueule tout le temps.
Tu sais, elle me regarde,
elle est comme ça—
Non, mais en fait, c'est dur de te maintenir,
parce que tu vraiment musclé, en fait.
Ah ! Attends,
t'as enregistré ou pas ?
Une force inouïe.
>> Oui, on a enregistré, elle a dit que j'étais musclé.
Si je mettais toute ma force,
ce serait un truc de ouf.
Ha ha ha !
Elle saoule !
Aïe ! Putain !
Vas-y ! Attends, mais là,
si je veux, attends,
non mais là, j'ai pas mis
toute ma, attends,
attends, mais là,
je mets, d'accord.
C'est bon ?
>> Ouais.
>> OK.
Attends, je suis stressé, là.
Là, je t'ai encore laissé faire, mais—
Putain, cette femme me détruit.
>> C'est bien, c'est réaliste, comme ça.
Oh, c'est Mamie qui m'a envoyé une petite carte
avec un petit chaton trop mignon, c'est adorable !
Y a pas de chèque ?
Y a pas de chèque !
Ben, je m'en bats les couilles, alors !
Cadeau suivant !